Speaker 1: All right, welcome, everybody,
let's jump right in, we haven't done a good
old fashioned a press briefing, wacky questions
segment in a little bit.
I checked in on the press briefing that took
place on Wednesday this week and some really
pretty wacky stuff is going on.
First of all, Fox News's Peter Doocy is still
trying to ask these gotchas of Jen Psaki.
She's actually increasingly well-prepared
to handle them.
And here is one where, after some comments
Joe Biden made, Peter Doocy is asking whether
if a parent doesn't like their kids curriculum,
they should be considered a domestic terrorist.
Extremely misleading.
I'll explain in a moment.
Speaker 2: Does the administration agree that
parents are upset about their kids curriculums
could be considered domestic terrorists?
Speaker 3: Well, let me unravel this a little
bit because the National School Board Association
is not a part of the U.S. government.
I'd point you to them.
What the Department of Justice said in a letter
from the attorney general is that quote Threats
against public servants are not only illegal.
They run counter to our nation's core values.
That is true.
These were threats against public servants.
Threats against members of the school board,
regardless of the reasoning, threats and violence
against public servants is illegal.
Speaker 1: Now you might be wondering what
on earth is Peter Doocy talking about?
And what he's talking about is the mobilization
of the federal government to some degree,
on the basis of escalated threats against
educators and the insanity that's happening
at the school board meetings.
The problem is not taking seriously the behavior
of parents at school board meetings.
That's what we should be doing.
The problem is that the school board meetings
are getting completely insane, and what this
entire thing is in reference to is that last
week, the National School Boards Association
pressed Biden for federal assistance to review
whether violence and threats against public
school officials could be considered a form
of domestic terrorism and hate crimes.
That's all that this is about.
And Peter, do you see, of course, has to make
it the most melodramatic thing possible?
Then Peter Doocy tries to make it a free speech
issue.
The problem is lunatic parents at the school
board meetings.
Then Doocy tries to make it a free speech
issue.
Does Biden support the right to protest?
Of course he does.
Speaker 2: Does the president support the
fundamental right of these parents to protest
at school work?
Speaker 3: Of course, but he doesn't stand
for the fundamental right.
I assume you don't, either.
For people to take violent action against
members of public servants.
And that's what the threats are about.
And so, no, he doesn't stand for that, right?
Speaker 1: It's one of these after another,
after another, just continuing to make something
not out of nothing, but make something out
of what you should be making the opposite
out of.
Why are all of these parents losing their
minds, going crazy at school board meetings,
attacking teachers, verbally assaulting, quoting
Hitler?
As we talked about last week on and on and
on, that's really the question.
And then just one other.
Here's a bonus one.
This is a different reporter saying Why hasn't
Joe Biden called Mitch McConnell to try to
get all of this stuff sorted out?
Referring to the bills and the double standard
here is notable.
Let's listen first.
Speaker 2: Why wouldn't the president given
that relationship he has with McConnell, just
call Mitch McConnell and have this conversation
with him?
Why do this?
Speaker 3: What's the conversation about?
Speaker 2: I don't know.
They have the relationship.
He's the one who said you could bring the
two sides together.
So wouldn't there be some value in having
that conversation?
Speaker 3: Know what the we know what the
risk free option is here.
We know what the clear path forward is here.
And I think the president has made no secret
about his belief on that.
Speaker 1: So I have no problem with Joe.
I've said it a million times when Joe Biden
brought Republicans to the White House and
some some people on the left are mad.
Some people on the right were mad.
Great.
Bring them give them an opportunity to weigh
in on the COVID stimulus bill that was back
then.
They don't want to participate.
Let them not participate.
And ultimately, that's what they did.
But you're not going to hold things up.
It's fine to talk to them when it was Trump.
Right?
The question was why won't Democrats give
Trump what he wants?
Why are Democrats getting in the way?
Why won't they concede anything at all?
Why?
Why, even though that was a completely dishonest
framing?
Now, much of the corporate media has switched
to why isn't Joe Biden talking to more Republicans
before?
The problem was Democrats weren't giving Trump
what he wanted.
Now, the problem is Joe Biden hasn't called
Mitch McConnell, but a couple of months ago,
when he actually did meet with Republicans,
then the problem was why is he giving Republicans
so much power, even though he didn't?
It's the need to constantly create the most
salacious possible narrative, even if it has
very little bearing on reality.
So that's the press briefing.
Let's now talk about Christmas.
When a Democratic president is in power very
often, Fox News talks about the war on Christmas
a lot, and we now have a pandemic which has
affected holidays for some time.
And Fox News is going absolutely crazy over
very milquetoast comments that Anthony Fauci
made.
I'm going to play the clip for you that started
it all.
Dr. Fauci was asked over the weekend.
Our Christmas gatherings, good to go.
And he responding to a question, said it's
just too early to say,
Speaker 4: but we can gather for Christmas
or it's just too soon to tell.
Speaker 5: You know, Margaret, it's just too
soon to tell.
We've just got to concentrating on continuing
to get those numbers down and not trying to
jump ahead by weeks or months and say what
we're going to do at a particular time.
Speaker 1: Fauci didn't cancel Christmas.
He didn't even come out and say, I must talk
about Christmas.
He was asked the question and he said, it's
just kind of early.
Fox News has now been going for 48 hours with
the idea that Fauci is canceling Christmas.
Look at these clips.
Here is Jason Rantz, who is a radio host in
Seattle.
Listen to this unhinged insanity.
Speaker 5: Seventy five percent or so to tell
me that it's not safe to visit your family
for Christmas.
To see that now in October indicates this
isn't really about public health at this point.
Now we're talking about taking total control.
Speaker 1: Now, understand what he did there,
this guy saying.
In October, Fauci saying No Christmas, no
in October found she's saying Christmas is
too far away to talk about Christmas.
We just need to see what's happening with
the virus.
Another example here is, I think this is Kennedy
saying, why is she talking about Christmas?
Well, he was asked about it.
He didn't come up with the question.
Speaker 3: Problem is, he's talking about
Christmas and Hanukkah.
We haven't gotten to Halloween and Thanksgiving
Columbus Day.
Thank you, Dana.
We're getting rid of that.
Kids did not get to have a Halloween last
year, right?
And it's like, you know, you have little kids,
you only have so many of them.
My daughter last year had to bake a twilight
cake
Speaker 1: with a gravestone.
OK, yeah.
Making drama where there is no drama.
Why is she talking about Christmas?
Because he was asked by Margaret Brennan about
Christmas.
That's why then the histrionics really get
going with Tucker Carlson.
Tucker, it's incredible what Tucker is able
to do with this.
The histrionic nature of this.
Take a look.
Speaker 5: There was do not travel for Christmas,
Anthony Fauci said.
Do not congregate together to celebrate it.
That means no Christmas Eve in church.
That means no Christmas morning under the
Speaker 1: tree with you.
It's an attack on religion like
Speaker 5: tearing through stockings.
It means no Christmas stockings.
Sacred Christian observance canceled until
further notice from Dr. Anthony Fauci, M.D..
What a thrill it must have been for him to
say something like that.
Oh yeah.
Here's a guy who fully expected to spend his
life giving prostate exams.
And there he was, declaring the ancient Christian
calendar null and
Speaker 1: void, by the way, is what it was.
Was Foushee heading towards urology as a spouse?
I don't even know what the prostate exam thing
even is, so tucker blowing it completely out
of the water.
Here's another right wing guy, Clay Travis,
saying Fauci's just trying to control holidays.
Speaker 5: Everyone, but I have to say it,
Foushee There the constitution matters the
most in times of emergency and crisis because
that's when the foundation of our country's
documents matter the absolute.
Speaker 1: Imagine Dr. Fauci, what do you
think about Christmas?
I don't know.
It's too soon to tell.
This guy is attacking the Constitution
Speaker 5: and the idea that he's trying to
argue to us that we can't celebrate Christmas
together.
And now he's saying, Oh, I didn't say that,
but you did say it.
He didn't say it.
Speaker 1: He didn't say it.
He said it's just too soon to tell.
And then lastly, here is one more of these,
and it's just more pathetic than the last.
Yes.
Speaker 3: After calling for the cancelation
of Christmas again, somehow Anthony Fauci
still has his job.
Speaker 1: Never happened.
Just never happened.
And this is how the narratives start and continue.
This one has the same texture as the Dr. Seuss,
who, by the way, is not a medical doctor.
Folks, you should know about that.
These people are pathetic, but they don't
have anything else.
So this is what they're doing.
Remember that on Tuesday, October 19th, we
will be doing a live viewer townhall.
It will be streaming live exclusively only
on the Pacman Live YouTube channel, which
you can find at YouTube.com slash Pacman Live.
It won't be streaming on Facebook.
It won't be streaming on Tik Tok.
It won't be on the main YouTube channel.
It won't be on Twitch.
The Pacman Live Channel six p.m. Eastern on
Tuesday, October 19th.
Everybody can call in members on our website.
Get Priority will be a great event, and I
hope to see all of you.
Then let's take a quick break and we have
quite a program planned
for
you today.
Welcome back to the show, everybody remember
that we are primarily funded by viewers and
listeners who sign up on my website.
You can find the membership signup form, very
extensive forum you put in, like your email
and you make a password at join Packman dot
com.
The normal membership rates I find to be really
a great deal, but what the hell do I know?
If you don't like the prices, though, you
can use the code better 21 and get a discount.
Not means tested open to everybody.
You decide.
Let's hear from some people in the audience.
One of the best parts of the week for many
a terrible part of the week.
For some others.
OK.
Right.
Let's just get into it.
It's via discord.
You can participate at David Pakman dot com
slash discord.
Let's start today with Caitlin from Alaska.
Caitlin from Alaska.
You were on the air.
Speaker 4: Can you hear me OK?
Speaker 1: I can hear you beautiful, OK?
One Yeah,
Speaker 4: perfect.
It's been a minute.
Glad to hear you're doing good.
I actually don't have a question.
I just wanted to give you a quick update here
from Alaska, please.
Since we made news with our fantastically
wonderful, you know, mask mandate discussion,
I.
Speaker 1: OK, Caitlin, right, as you were
about to get into the substance, you glitched
out, tell us again what's happening now in
Alaska?
Speaker 4: I personally don't know anyone
who's passed away from COVID.
My work is very strict with our guidelines,
so no one is allowed into our office without
being vaccinated.
And even with that, we've had one person catch
COVID.
We've had two others who have been in contact
with somebody and had to quarantine.
My sister is a hairdresser and she sees like
100 people a week, and she's been lucky enough
to not catch COVID right.
So it seems to me that even though Alaska
is doing absolutely atrocious with everyone
I know, we're all very well.
We always wear our masks outside of the house.
OK, so it seems like for those of us here
in Anchorage, as long as you still continue
with the mitigation efforts, along with being
fully vaccinated, most people are safe.
So the numbers are terrifying and I really,
really wish we didn't have such a.
Ignorant mayor.
But I mean, as long as people are intelligent
and use their brain, we seem to be doing OK.
Speaker 1: All right, very good.
Caitlin, thank you.
How many hours of daylight do you have right
now up there?
Speaker 4: The sun's rising right now, it's
eight, 12, I would say it usually sets around
six or seven right now.
Speaker 1: OK, so it's starting to become
more a little more normal, I guess
Speaker 4: normal for other people?
Yes.
Yeah.
Very good.
Speaker 1: All right, Caitlyn, thank you.
Always great hearing from Alaska.
OK.
Thank you, Caitlin, apparently disappearing,
they're very good.
Well, we got our Alaska update, which is a
great start.
Why don't we go next to John from Kentucky
and see what's going on there?
John, what's what's happening?
Speaker 6: Hi, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes.
Are you calling from an airplane?
Speaker 6: I'm calling from a car.
Give me one second.
Speaker 1: Oh God, no, no.
It's not bad.
It's nice.
Ambient noise.
Speaker 6: Okay.
Well, perfect.
Yeah, I was.
I was calling because I had a question on
de-radicalize and left him, to be honest.
OK.
I personally identify principally as a socialist,
but I've recognized in my time growing up
with this particular like ideology that reality
does tend to skew liberal, both from the left
wing and also the right wing like, for example.
It's frustrating when I talk to my socialist
friends who want to pretend like there's going
to be a violent revolution of the proletariat.
Yeah, and I just have to look at them like,
are you guys living in the same reality as
me?
Or similarly, with the anti-vax stuff, people
taking the big pharma to incredibly insane
conclusions?
I was just wondering if there was any way
to kind of engage with these sort of things
from a center perspective without coming off
as like a like a shill for liberalism or.
Speaker 1: Sure.
Now just to be clear, you're saying you are
a socialist, but you want to talk these talk
to these folks more from a centrist perspective,
is that what you're saying?
Speaker 6: Yeah, principally I recognize that.
Yeah, I do think it's a little bit messed
up that we have more empty houses than we
have homeless people in America, for example,
and that is kind of terrible.
That's locked behind a privatized system.
That being said, in our current system, it's
probably a good thing that landlords can evict
people who aren't taking care of their investment.
Speaker 1: I see.
I mean, listen with that in terms of the people
who are expecting or waiting or hoping for
a violent uprising, you know, by the proletariat,
I think it makes sense to sort of talk through
exactly how that would happen and importantly,
the number of people that might be killed
or maimed in such a revolution and see if
they feel like that the ends would justify
the means.
Some might say yes, some might say no, but
I think it's good to just have them walk you
through all of the steps, if that makes sense.
Now I've got to ask, are you driving a V8
with knobby tires?
Speaker 6: I'm actually just driving a good
old fashioned 2014 Ford Fusion, I have no
clue what kind of tires
Speaker 4: are on here.
Wow, wow.
Speaker 1: OK, well, listen, John, good luck
with the deradicalisation and report back
if you are able to effectively do any of it.
Speaker 6: OK, well, thank you very much for
your time.
All right.
Speaker 1: Pleasure, John from Kentucky.
Very strong first couple of calls.
Not great audio there on that second one,
but we're going to deal with it.
Let's go next to Alex from Baltimore, Maryland.
Alex, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hey, David didn't hear me.
I can.
Speaker 7: Hey, great, so I have a question
about moderates in general, so I feel like
a popular take from the left is that anyone
who has a moderate, even if it's a liberal
viewpoint, is therefore corrupt and therefore
a shill.
Hmm.
Do you believe that to be true?
And how do you tell the difference between
the two?
No.
Speaker 1: So you know that thing about like
you can, you know, porn when you see it?
I think people know grifter and enlightened
centrist positions when they see them versus
someone who's just moderate.
I think there's a difference between staking
out positions of neutrality to be perceived
as some kind of, you know, above the fray
centrist.
And it's often very disingenuous and very
transparent versus there are issues on which
people can just genuinely be moderate, and
it doesn't mean they've sold out to anyone.
There could be, you know, think about taxation.
There are people who might think that the
top tax rate should be 90 percent and some
who think there should be no taxes or a five
percent flat tax.
And you're going to come across someone who
just thinks, Hey, look, I don't know, it should
be 42 percent a little bit higher than we
have now.
But that's it just because they're at 42 and
someone else is at 37 and someone else is
at 20.
There's no particular reason to say if you
end up in the middle you, it's because of
a corrupting influence.
There's no substantive basis to believe that
that's different than people who just sort
of frame themselves as neutral and centrist
on everything to pretend to be above bias.
You understand the distinction I'm making.
Speaker 7: Yeah, I do.
And that's kind of how I feel.
I just it's just actually my comment was more
about the commentary of how other.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Stream that because you're a moderate.
Yep.
You are.
Therefore, you are correct.
Speaker 4: No, I think
Speaker 1: I think that
Speaker 4: that's wrong.
Yeah.
You believe?
Speaker 1: No, I don't believe it either.
And I guess that's my point.
There's no there's no there's no substantive
reason to assume that because someone is moderate
on an issue, their view is corrupted by whatever.
No, I disagree with people who think that
whether they're on the left or right.
Speaker 7: Fair enough.
And I do have a I have a quick travel question
for you because you again, I call it a little
bit a while ago about travel stuff.
I have young kids.
Where would you recommend a foreign country
that is more kid friendly?
Speaker 1: Oh my goodness, I have no idea.
What does it mean?
Kid friendly?
I mean, there's millions of children in countries
all over the world.
Speaker 7: That is true.
I guess my thinking on that would be is, you
know, things that we as adults said to explore
other countries would be fine.
Wouldn't that be fun for a six year old?
Right?
I guess other places where they would have
things for kids as well and not just, you
know, old cultural stuff that you and I would
find interesting, but yeah, a six or eight
year old would
Speaker 4: I have no
Speaker 1: idea what a six or eight year old
finds?
Interesting, to be perfectly frank, I'm so
poorly positioned to answer the question.
Speaker 7: No, that's fair.
There's just more of a fun question to ask
you, and I have one last quickie food debate.
Sure, it is autumn for whatever you prefer
to call it.
Sure.
Pumpkin spice or apple cider flavor?
Speaker 1: Oh my God.
I don't do either, but I will have an occasional
cider donut, so I guess I'd go cider cider
flavor rather than than pumpkin spice.
Speaker 7: It is a that's a fair point.
I thoroughly enjoy both, but I figured that
was, you know, you're from the Northeast.
I figured that.
Be a big question for you.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah.
No, the pumpkin spice stuff.
I'm seeing everybody with their pumpkin spice
lattes that are half whipped cream with.
It's just it should be illegal.
That's my view.
Speaker 7: I don't know.
I turn to a very basic white girl this time
of year.
Speaker 4: So all right, my friend on that
way.
Speaker 1: But thank you very much for the
call.
Likewise, yeah.
Thanks very much.
Yeah, no.
I, by the way, I don't think pumpkin spice
should be illegal.
I just, you know, it's not, for me, I guess,
is the point that I'm trying to make.
Let's go next to Shane from State College
is that is that State College, Pennsylvania.
Is yes.
OK.
Yeah, I don't know how it is that is the town
called State College, I never understood it.
Speaker 4: Yeah, it's it's the, I guess, the
main campus for Penn.
Penn State University in the town is called
State College.
Speaker 1: Fascinating.
All right.
Well, what's going on?
Speaker 4: Not much pleasure to speak with
you really enjoy the show.
I have a quick question.
Would you ever consider doing a longform discussion
with Jordan Peterson?
I know you and he have a lot of disagreements.
I think it'll be fascinating to hear you.
Two Go back and forth for a couple of hours.
Speaker 1: Sure.
He's been on before and he's welcome back
any time.
Speaker 4: OK.
I think that would be I think a lot of people
would benefit from from seeing that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I guess I'd be too
big for the David Pakman show now.
I don't know that he would do it, quite frankly.
Oh, is that right?
Yeah, I mean, I don't know, I don't think
there's a guarantee that Peterson needs, needs
or wants to appear on my show right now.
Speaker 4: And I guess the other question
with that is, what are your current thoughts
on the Iaw and what do you say about?
Because I've read different forums and things
and some people have placed you in that crowd.
What do you think of them and what's going
on?
Speaker 1: Oh, yeah, I don't know anything
about that, but I honestly haven't thought
of, thought about or seen anything about the
intellectual dark web for, I would say, a
year or longer.
I don't know.
I don't know if it still exists.
I just have no idea whatsoever.
I mean, do they are they still have they disbanded?
Was it ever really banded?
I just have no idea, it seems.
Correct me if I'm wrong, but it seems as though
the relevance and number of mentions have
declined dramatically.
Speaker 4: That's what I've noticed as well,
and I didn't even think it was a formal group,
I thought it was just sort of like a loose
collection of similar kind of thinkers and
whatnot.
Now I know, and I haven't heard you talk about
this guy very much, but I don't know if you've
been following Bret Weinstein and The Dark
Horse podcast and some of the things that
they've been saying over there.
Speaker 1: No, I have.
I'm aware of the, you know, spike protein
is cytotoxic phase and the ivermectin is fantastic
phase and all of these different.
I am aware of what's going on, but I've taken
mostly a Sam Harris approach where it's very
hard to really like go point counterpoint
because they kind of put out a fire hose of
stuff.
And if they mention one thing you're not prepared
for or can immediately refute, it comes off
as though they're really making good points.
And so, you know, for similar reasons.
As Sam Harris has stated, I'm not like super
directly engaging with it.
Speaker 4: That that kind of corresponds with
my take on it as as well, because I did actually
follow the the podcast he and his wife did
for a while, but then as time wore on, I just
found that I wasn't resonating with what they
were saying quite as much, and I had to do
a lot more kind of digging to really.
Kind of see if what they were saying squared
with, you know what the vast majority of other
experts were saying.
And eventually I just decided that they weren't
for me.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's fair.
That's completely fair.
Everybody should make informed decisions about
media consumption.
I'm glad you did.
Speaker 4: Absolutely.
Well, I think that's it for me, but real of
the show, support what you're doing.
Thank you very
Speaker 1: much.
My pleasure.
Thank you so much for the call.
We're going to take just a very brief break,
but we're going to continue the calls.
So if you're holding on to talk to me, unless
you're furious at how long you've been holding
and are about to hang up in a rage, just hold
on another moment and we're going to go right
back to the Discord lines in a second.
All right, let's hear from a few more people
today, we are now taking calls via Discord.
It typically works really, really well.
You can find the discord at David Pakman Gqom
slash discord.
Let's go across the pond.
I hope I'm pronouncing this correctly.
Is it shanese in the United Kingdom?
Speaker 4: Hi, yes.
Can you hear me,
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine, are you calling
in from Nottingham?
Speaker 4: I am, yes.
What a pleasure in the UK.
What a pleasure.
Thanks.
I'm a huge fan of the show.
Thank you.
My question was I was just wondering, why
do you think that the left kind of branding
and messaging is generally so much less successful
than the right?
I feel as though whenever you know, the left
come up with something like defund the police
or something like that, it just kind of tends
to cause like a lot of infighting.
It doesn't really tend to kind of let go as
well, whereas when the right come up with
something, it always tends to kind of work
a little bit better.
Do you think it's just kind of I feel as if
it's almost like the bully in the playground
let.
The right's voice is just louder.
They kind of just go along with points without
really any kind of evidence, but it tends
to work better for them than it does kind
of for us on the left.
Speaker 1: Beautiful question.
So I think that there's two answers depending
on the circumstances.
So sometimes the left just comes up.
Just brands a bad idea.
OK, so like defund the police wasn't a good
idea.
It was a bad idea.
And as I explained in my ten point police
reform plan, reallocation of resources?
Yes, reform replacing police with social workers
for some types of calls, yes.
But in some places, you might need to increase
funding for police in order to accomplish
those things or to be at the proper level
of staffing in order to have police be more
proactive than reactive.
OK, so like defund the police was a bad idea
because as a slogan, because the idea itself
is not a good idea, that's one side.
Right?
But there's a whole other set of examples
which are sometimes the left assumes that
because we have the right idea that the branding
doesn't matter and we just have to explain
the idea and everybody will like it.
And the right who has the wrong idea is like,
that doesn't really matter.
We just need a slogan and they come up with
a slogan and it works.
I mean, pro-life is a great example, and so
is tax relief.
Pro-Life?
Well, actually, what you're doing is you're
picking and choosing certain medical situations
that should be left to patients and doctors
and assigning a name to it where if you're
against it, it's like, Wow, that you're anti
anti-life.
If you're not pro-life, your entire life,
by definition, that's really good branding,
even though the policy makes no sense tax
relief any time taxes go down.
It's the relief of a burden.
So even though the real situation with taxes
is you need well-balanced taxes and well allocated
in order to pay for the things that we all
expect would be paid for through taxation,
tax relief less.
Listen, we're relieving people of this burden.
So sometimes the left is completely correct
on the position and they assume that the facts
alone will win people over.
And the right's like, No, we can just come
up with a better slogan.
So two different categories, they're seniors.
Speaker 4: It makes perfect sense, I really
agree with what you're saying, I also think
I liked what you were saying the other day
as well about these kind of politicians who
seem to kind of be doing everything with the
coronavirus like wrong and incorrectly, they
could kind of be called let pro-vaccine.
I think things like that is like a really
good idea
Speaker 1: to throw virus.
You mean pro virus?
Speaker 4: Yeah, pre-virus.
Sorry.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, no, definitely.
I mean, let's call them what they are.
They seem to be on the side of the virus and
especially when, OK, they might refuse the
vaccine, but you're also going to refuse getting
tested.
Like, what's the reason?
That doesn't make any sense.
So yeah, these are all relevant examples.
Speaker 4: OK, thank you so much for answering
my questions.
Speaker 1: My pleasure, I appreciate the call.
All right, SHINee's from Nottingham, UK.
Great, great call.
Why don't we go next to, you know, we tried
last time and it didn't work?
Let's go to Eric from Cancun, Mexico.
Eric, are you with us this time?
Speaker 4: David, hello.
Yes.
It's a great pleasure to talk to you.
I've been trying for months and weeks.
Here's the thing I'm thinking and I'm my family
wants to get a passport to us and I like to
visit the Facebook.
I've been seeing your videos and from of cousins
and the young Turks.
And I've seen very deranged individuals, all
surveillance and the police and army.
I think it's the same for tourists and foreigners
to go there with all the wackos and psychopaths
around.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, everybody needs
to do their own risk assessment, but statistically
speaking, statistically speaking, the U.S.
is not an unsafe place to be.
You know, there are safer and less safe places
in the U.S., the big country.
In the big cities, you have to take the normal
precautions that you take in any big city,
but you need to make that assessment.
I mean, the U.S. is not an unsafe place to
go to statistically.
But that doesn't mean bad things don't happen.
Bad things happen all the time.
You really have to make that call.
Speaker 4: And yeah, I'm I'm really with the
mindset that I like in the song Father of
a Bill of Forever Young hoping for the best
with explained words like what happened in
that Molino parcel and other things.
I mean, the martial artists in, say, years
old.
Would they be legal for me to defend myself?
Or would I be charged with assault if I fight
back?
Speaker 1: I think you would be perfectly
within your legal rights to defend yourself,
regardless of your martial arts training.
Speaker 4: And yeah, I mean, it's like, why
don't you grab my guy and cowboy you that
I love jujitsu and karate?
Yeah.
And.
And it's been a pleasure.
And one great thing.
Do you remember when Republicans were mad
that Dr. Seuss?
Speaker 1: Yes.
And you know, he's not even a real doctor,
he's not a medical doctor.
Speaker 4: It's and I think they would be
angry because they made it both about choices
for the relatives, for example.
He's left leaning uncle the Lorax.
He's nutty, but logic calls have stirred the
sour kangaroo, and he is more handsome and
more wholesome, cussing the Grinch.
Speaker 1: And you think very nice, very nice.
Eric, I love it.
How how is Cancun?
Which part of Cancun do you live in the downtown
or where?
Speaker 4: And in the heart of downtown, it's
pretty nice, it's like sound that all year,
but the winter is coming racing.
Speaker 1: It's beautiful.
All right, Eric, thank you so much for the
call.
We love our Mexican viewers.
If you all right, there is Eric Eric from
Cancun, what a call, folks, what a call.
Maybe my new favorite caller, I have to tell
you.
Let's go next to.
How about Enrique from North Carolina, you're
on the air.
Speaker 4: Hi, David.
Yes.
So starting company, please.
So my question is, do you know anything about
the features line up for that?
No doctor?
Speaker 1: I mean, it's I've been saying for
a very long time that there we need a permanent
solution when it comes to Dako, it just we
just need it.
It has to happen.
But I am not aware.
I wish I could tell you, I think it's coming
soon.
I don't really think it's coming soon.
I don't.
Not this year, anyway.
Oh, yeah.
Are you're at your adaka recipient?
Speaker 4: Yeah, I was born here when I was
one year old.
Speaker 1: Sorry.
You were born here or brought here at one
year old.
I miss that.
Speaker 4: Oh, I was brought here.
One year
Speaker 1: old.
That makes sense.
Yeah, most people are born at zero, not at
one.
I figured I misheard.
Speaker 4: Oh, yes.
Speaker 1: And how old are you now?
Yes.
Speaker 4: I'm 21 now.
Speaker 1: Wow, so this is this is really
your country.
Speaker 4: Oh, yeah.
I mean, I know more, I'm more American than
I am.
I love I love Mexican culture.
I grew up in American culture.
You know, I speak English.
This is America.
Anyone here?
Speaker 1: For sure?
Yeah.
I mean, if if if someone came to you and said,
Sir, you've got to go back to Mexico.
I can only imagine how devastating that would
be.
Speaker 4: I would be freaking out.
I don't know what I would do.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah, well, listen, I'm with
you.
We need a solution.
I hope that that we get to it sooner than
later.
But realistically, it doesn't seem like there's
a political appetite to get it done this this
year at minimum.
Speaker 4: Now.
All right, thank you, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Thank you so much for calling in.
Yeah, I mean, you know, millions of people
in that situation, millions, millions, it
millions, maybe it's not now I misremember,
is it?
Hundreds of thousands, many people, many people.
Let's go next to Josie from Michigan.
Josie, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: What's up, David?
How are you doing?
Good.
I just wanted to know, what do you think about
the 30 U.S. schoolchildren still stuck in
Afghanistan right now?
Speaker 1: I'm not aware of the number of
people left.
What are the circumstances?
Were they on like some kind of summer trip
or something?
Believe it or not,
Speaker 4: they were on a school trip.
I don't know who takes their schoolchildren
to Afghanistan.
Speaker 1: That's my question.
I mean, it's now I know that sometimes when
people say, how on earth would you take kids,
people come back and say, there's much to
learn culturally.
Historically, I don't deny that.
I don't deny that.
I just don't understand, given the security
situation, who who would do that?
What age kids are there.
They high schoolers, do you know?
Speaker 4: I think I heard something along
the lines of one of the principal or one of
the students.
Dad is a U.S. official or something like that.
And they were going, No.
Speaker 1: Have they?
Do we know?
I don't know anything about the story.
Have Joe Biden's administration has said anyone
who wants to get out, we will help get out.
There's no time limit on it.
Like, Are they are?
Is there?
Is this in the middle of a process or what's
going on?
Speaker 4: Yeah, it's really hard to find
information on at this point because even
if you google it, at this point, it only shows
articles up to like September 3rd and then
there's been no word on it since it's been
mentioned, really?
Speaker 1: Is it possible they got out?
But there just haven't been articles written
because there's less of a story once they're
just back in the U.S..
Speaker 4: That's possible.
I don't know.
I just thought it would be newsworthy.
You would think you would think.
Speaker 1: And I mean, listen, like I've said
before, we've got to support everybody who
wants to get out.
Joe Biden said there's no time limit.
If you don't want to get out now and then
in a month, you do.
He says the U.S. will help and do everything
that the government can, so let's hope they
stick to it.
Speaker 4: Yeah, let's hope.
All right.
Good talking to you, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Thanks for the call.
There's Jose from Michigan.
A lot of lot of good questions today.
Let's try a different country just for kicks.
How about Fiona from Germany?
Fiona, you're on the air.
Speaker 8: Hello.
I well thought about the Afghanistan topic
again.
And we have data on how much civilian support
staff has been working with the military.
But the data has been collected by civilian
organizations and only made available to government
or listened to by the government as recently
as like the 10th of September.
And I would like to know the American situation.
Do you think that would be listened to if
a civilian organization would like mentioned
civilian support staff that may or may not
be interested in leaving Afghanistan?
And if so, would there be assistance rendered?
Speaker 1: I apologize.
I'm not sure I understand the question.
You're saying the American civilian support
staff currently in Afghanistan, is that who
we're talking about?
Speaker 8: No civilian Afghan support staff
that happened to support European troops is
also been evacuated.
How are you?
Very small situation and share.
Speaker 1: Are you listening to some video
in the background?
I just heard someone say, Hi, how are you?
No.
Oh, that was weird.
I don't know.
I mean, I don't know if they would qualify
for asylum or refugee status.
I'm I'm just not sure.
It's very hard for me to answer that question.
I just don't know.
Speaker 8: Yeah, it's a convoluted thing.
Yeah, it just popped in my mind.
But thank you for calling on me.
Speaker 1: Oh, no problem.
How are things in Germany?
OK?
Speaker 8: They have been very good, good.
Speaker 1: Excellent.
I spent 24 hours there last month and it was
fantastic.
Speaker 8: Well.
That's my fear.
Yeah, I hope to be back any of the political
campaigning.
Speaker 1: And in Germany, no, I have not.
No, I.
Speaker 8: It was very startling to me when
it appeared, and it was so tiny and small.
You didn't see that other countries.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, that's for sure.
All right.
Thank you so much for the call.
OK, very good.
Let's hear from a couple of other people.
Why don't we go to Nathan from California?
Nathan, you're on the air.
Speaker 9: Hey, David.
I work in the wedding industry and a recently
a local politician has caught some flack on
the news for attending a private event.
And I just wanted to know what your thoughts
on kind of like the hypocrisy of politicians
saying that you should wear a mask indoors
while they're attending these private events?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I mean, listen, there's obvious hypocrisy.
There's no question about it.
Also, sometimes public health guidelines are
supported at a governmental level and individuals
assess their own risk and they do different
things.
I mean, OK, you know, it doesn't make it not
hypocritical.
It just is something that happens.
I don't know about the event.
You know, sometimes people go to I've gone
to a couple of events where everybody's got
to be vaccinated and gets a test on the way
in.
And then like, I went to a dinner with 10
people like that last month, and that seemed
quite reasonable.
And and we don't know what the testing requirement
is.
I'm about to go to a wedding where everybody's
going to be tested.
So I don't know.
I mean, of course, there's some level of hypocrisy.
And then at the same time, I think a lot of
the stuff is in the details.
Speaker 9: OK.
I mean, do you think like at a certain point,
the personal responsibility will be kind of
like the data ultimately is the thing that
people want to take upon themselves outside
of, like these mass mandates?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I think it's going
to go more and more in that direction.
And like Dr. Isaac Bogoch last week told us,
once we really have a high enough level of
vaccination and hopefully the virus becomes
less serious where the death risk goes down
even more, then it becomes more about each
individual making that decision for themselves.
We're not at that point right now for a number
of different reasons.
The virus is still far more serious than the
flu, and not not nearly enough people are
vaccinated.
So yes, it's going to go more and more towards
just personal decisions, but we're nowhere
near that yet.
Speaker 9: Awesome.
Thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Very good question.
Appreciate it.
All right.
Thanks to everybody who called in.
That's going to do it for today.
We'll take calls again and I'll speak to more
people.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.
All right, let's get into this week's mailbag.
I got a weird email from someone last week
saying I should call this my apple bag, which
is just strange.
I think it relates to that weird Nicki Minaj
story, and I talked about apple bags, but
I don't think Apple Bags is an appropriate
name for this segment.
This is the mailbag.
You can participate maybe if your email is
interesting and smart enough or crazy enough,
right?
There's two types by emailing info at David
Pakman VK.com.
This has been an increasingly popular segment.
Emails are just dumping in people wanting
their questions answered.
Let's just get right into it.
Folks, please.
Starting with Brian, Brian wrote.
I don't even care that Brian spelled my name
wrong.
He says, Mr. Pacman, I enjoy your show.
I have heard you comment a few times about
Donald Trump misstating the 1918 Spanish flu
by repeating 1917 Spanish flu.
He is not getting this wrong on accident.
17 is a Q and on reference or Conan, as some
say or shout out, every time he uses 17 incorrectly,
it is done purposefully.
Thank you for what you do.
Yeah, we had a caller last week on live calls
who said the same thing, which is Q, is the
17th letter of the alphabet, right?
So Ms 13 and 14 15 P16 Q 17, that part checks
out.
Maybe that's true.
I've now heard this from a few people.
Maybe, yeah, I don't know, and if that's the
case, it would be really disturbing about
what it says about former President Trump
that he is sort of surreptitiously signaling
to the QAnon conspiracy theories.
I would put nothing past Trump whatsoever.
Part of me wonders whether he's clever or
smart enough to even do that.
Maybe somebody gave him the idea.
I think the most likely explanation is also
the simplest one Trump misstated the 1918
flu is the 1917 flu once.
Nobody corrected him or they did.
But Trump is too much of a narcissist to change
it because it would concede that he said something
wrong.
So he's just continuing to call it the 1917
flu.
That's my sort of guess.
Next, the email is from a way.
No way, no, says Sir.
How does YouTube's ban on misinformation affect
Joe Rogan?
It's a good question.
I think you're referring to YouTube banning
all anti-vax stuff.
It's pretty clear to me that Joe Rogan is
staying on this side of the YouTube rules.
Some of his guests may be on their own.
Channels are going past that line, but my
instinct in looking at the updated rules.
And remember that the updated rules from YouTube
about they've banned anti-vaxxers and anti-vax
content.
It it was already in place for COVID vaccine
stuff.
They've just expanded it to be all anti-vax
And so since the controversial subject matter
on Rogan's channel has been about when it
comes to vaccines, the COVID vaccine.
That ban was already in place, so I don't
actually think that the new rules will really
affect Rogan.
A lot of people may not know this, but there's
much more content demonetized on YouTube than
there is removed.
There's actually, I mean, of course, like
straight up gore and violence and out and
out conspiracy anti-vax stuff.
It's removed.
The vast majority of content is just demonetized
when it violates terms and conditions.
So my belief is Joe Rogan is not going to
be affected by this in any way.
Next email today is from Daniel.
Daniel says evidence the Pentagon has gave
way more money to the Wuhan lab, then Dr.
Fauci's NIH, and the fact that Peter Daszak
is the main one who gave all that money to
the Wuhan scientists directly and how one
seems to care.
I think what Daniel is trying to say is that
despite what he believes to be evidence about
money going from the NIH to the Wuhan lab,
that no one seems to care.
I believe that that's what this email is about.
Listen, I've weighed in on this before.
My view is I want to know the truth about
the world period.
I am not.
This is not a show where either for posturing
or for narrative crafting or for any reason,
I exclude things from the show that I believe
are important or lie to the audience in any
way.
I always give my opinion.
I want to know the truth about the Wuhan lab
and funding and Dr. Fauci and the entire thing.
I think what's important is that we understand,
first of all, how much of this entire Dr.
Fauci controversy fundamentally comes down
to semantics, which I talked about last week
on the Friday show with a caller who called
in.
That's number one and number two.
There is a lot of misinformation about this
issue.
So I continue to look when things come across
my desk or my screen, as it might better be
said into the new Wuhan issue.
And if I have some kind of major thing to
come to you with and say, Sirs and M&Ms, here's
some news.
You can rest assured that I will do that.
Let's go to the next email.
This is very weaponized.
Now, I should actually even take it off the
screen for a second.
If there are kids in the room, get them out.
If you have dogs that are particularly sensitive
to cringe.
Get them out, cats.
They don't give a damn what the hell is on
the screen.
But in all seriousness, this is very, very
weaponized.
William wrote to me and said they all died.
David, I am the only member of my family and
friend group who was smart enough to not listen
to celebrity propaganda.
And unfortunately, I was right.
Almost everyone I know personally has died
from a vaccine.
My mother and I are the only ones left.
She took the vaccine, but thankfully her immune
system kicked it out.
That's actually it.
So it's so crazy.
It's funny.
What am I supposed to do now that everybody
I know and love is dead because of your stupid
vaccine?
Does this even deserve a reply?
Like, I don't even I'm not even, you know,
this is either someone, I mean, like, what?
What is this, right?
OK, so it could be just someone who's trolling.
Fine.
Let's imagine it's not.
This could be someone whose family really
has tragically died from different issues,
could be even covered, and they are wrongly
blaming it on being vaccinated.
Also, they say, from a vaccine, not necessarily
even COVID.
So it could be someone who is mis attributing
death to vaccines.
Could be someone who's completely delusional
and disconnected from the real world.
I don't know.
Could could be a serial murderer who has killed
people and is saying it was vaccine.
This could be anything other than what it
purports to be.
I think that that's sort of where I would
leave it.
But these folks are out there.
Anthony wrote to me and said misleading characterization.
Mr. Pacman, it is often stated in the media
that most Republicans believe Trump won the
2020 election.
Wouldn't it be more accurate to say that most
Republicans claim they believe Trump won the
election?
Big difference?
No, this is a beautiful question.
We talked about this before, and we talked
about this in a segment where I talked about
the kind of magical thinking and we're at
war mentality of many of these Trump supporters
where we wondered when they say, we believe
Trump won.
Do they really believe it?
Or is it the way they are choosing to answer
polls in order to be part of the right team
and in order to perpetuate some more general
idea that they don't like Joe Biden?
They don't like that Joe Biden won.
And I think that I know I've been citing this
a lot lately, but Neil Postman in Technopolis
has a very good couple of pages about exactly
this issue, about opinion polling, which is
opinion polling.
We opinion polling becomes an invisible technology
in the sense that we just look at the results
of the poll and we don't think about why was
it done?
Who did it?
What does it really mean to answer questions
in one way or the other?
And how were the questions asked?
And what a poll tells us is an opinion poll
tells us what people claim to believe, and
people might claim to believe something they
don't believe for different reasons.
We talked, you know, there was this idea that
the the polls leading into 2020 that said
Joe Biden was winning were wrong because the
wrong people were being polled right sampling
problem.
Or there were people up bashful Trump supporters
not willing to say that they supported Trump,
but they really did.
It ended up basically being false.
I mean, Wisconsin was off, there's no doubt
about it, but it basically was not true.
But when it comes to what people believe about
the 2020 election, it's important to say that
the polls tell us what people claim to believe,
and they may not actually believe the things
they claim to believe for a whole bunch of
different reasons.
Very good point.
A next email is from Larry Larry says, Keep
drinking the now.
It gets crazy now, by the way.
Keep drinking the Kool-Aid.
Biden is the worst president in my lifetime
a liar, a wife stealer, and he has been selling
out our country for his family's benefit for
decades.
It sounds like Larry's describing Trump.
Quite frankly, Larry goes on to say Trader
Joe's where everything is for sale.
Big Fart.
Here we go with this stuff.
Big Pharma must also love you.
They are also a criminal organization.
And have you convinced hook, line and sinker
that they are our savior?
Open your eyes, young man.
So the first part is just whacked.
I mean, like, hard whacked the last part.
You know, a bunch of people have written in
and they've said, David, clearly you're being
paid to promote vaccines.
And I tweeted about this earlier in the week.
Why would anyone pay me to promote, like,
first of all, promote a report on the science
of vaccines?
But why would anyone pay me to promote vaccines?
Were it were small potatoes, right?
Like in the grand scheme of things, it would
be sort of a dumb thing to do.
And in addition, why would they pay me given
that I've reported on the science of vaccines
for a long time, like they don't?
What else can I really say about vaccines
other than reporting when they work and what
the impact of those vaccinations is?
And this is part of the sort of superstructure
around vaccination disinformation that's out
there, which is that some of the people there's
lies being told it's all lies is the point.
There's lies being told about how safe the
vaccine is.
That's the people who email in.
And they say thousands, tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands of people died from
the vaccine.
That's one part.
But then also the people telling you what
they claim is the science of vaccines.
Those people have been paid, so they simply
can't be believed.
It looks like they're giving you science,
but they're giving you stuff they've been
given by someone that paid them.
And the whole point of it is not to just accept
reality and live it in this other world, which
is preferable to them.
It's a preferable world to them.
It's simpler.
And that's the appeal of some conspiracy theories.
A lot of people.
Find it hard to accept.
That bad things happen, unpredictable things
happen every hundred years or so, we get a
100 year pandemic, but we've got a vaccine
that helps.
That sounds out of control to a lot of people.
It's more appealing to believe this was all
just done by humans.
That's where you get the vaccine.
I'm sorry.
The virus was created in a bioweapons lab
and released because that's control.
It's not a random event, it's not a probabilistic
event anymore, and the vaccine is also part
of the exact same plot.
It's all a plot for some people, even though
they claim to be outraged by it.
They would rather live in a world where everything
is controlled by man rather than than things
that can happen, that are left to chance,
unpredictable bad things that's at the root
of much conspiracy ism.
OK, last one today.
Here's a bonus.
This one came in via Facebook on Monday morning.
This is from George.
This is really wild, George says.
You keep calling Trump supporters delusional.
I truly hope that you open your eyes before
the Communist Democrat Nazi Party.
Come for you.
Few contradictions there.
Trump did not lose the 2020 election.
It was part of a Cullors revolution cullors.
Revolution, educate yourself, educate your
followers and open your eyes, otherwise you
might just find your.
You might find yourself on that train, just
like the Jews found themselves on a Nazi train.
Except this time it won't be gas.
It'll be an injection.
They call it a vaccine.
Dumb ass.
Folks, folks, this is what we're up against.
We're going to have to try to solve the problems
of humanity despite people like this.
I don't see any way to get them to help us.
Maybe we can prevent them from hurting us.
Maybe.
But it is not looking very good.
Not looking very good.
Get your emails in for next week's mailbag
info at David Pakman dot com.
We have a fantastic bonus show today.
It's all meet today on the bonus show.
I know many people expecting only producer
pat today.
It's all me.
Speaker 4: I will see
you
Unidentified: on the bonus, Kevin.